l'écrivain du samedi ce soir nous allons
faire la connaissance de michel butor
associé à l' aventure du nouveau roman
cet auteur a exploré temps de piste
qu'il est difficile à classer
ils habitent dans les alpes où il
travaille à sa manière unique
j'écris pour changer la vie parce que je
trouve que les choses ne sont pas bien
comme elles sont et c'est l'évidence
dans cet horrible fin de siècle que nous
vivons et j'estime que l'action la plus
forte c'est l'action sur le langage
en ce temps fuyant devant les tartares
nous marchions vers le nord périlleux en
pleine nuit sur la route de paint via la
lune éclairant les monts de l'eau
blanche tribut à garde dans sa longue
marche
honteux quand nous passions devant
quelqu'un les corbeaux croissait dans
les ravins personne ne venait en sens
inverse et eurent beaucoup de mal à
utiliser ce mot c'est un mot qui
m'intimide beaucoup mais comme on a dit
à mon sujet que j'étais un poète alors
j'en suis très fier je l'admets et
j'admets que ce que j'écris c'est de la
poésie parce que dans son univers tout
fait signe michel butor m accompagner
ses moues plus loin goûtant leur
plasticité jusque dans le concret c'est
aussi pourquoi son parcours croise celui
d'autres artistes peintres sculpteurs ou
metteurs en scène d'objets si juste
juste un peu plus c'est dégueulasse
affolée ma petite fille me mordais
s'écrit risquait d'attirer tigre et loup
je lui couvraient la bouche en lacérant
se dégageant elle hurlait encore plus
fort mon fils
beaucoup plus raisonnables trompé sa
femme avec des prunes sur un jour sur
deux tombé l'orage main dans la main
nous traînions dans la boue